welcome to this video coverage of the
final round for the candidates
tournament and of course the tournament
is decided but still games to be played
and yeah here we have got again between
Levon Aronian plain white and Sega
kayaking playing black Aronian or one of
the pre-tournament favourites probably
the favorite of the tournament didn't
really turn out to be in the in the best
shape possible and with the loss he
suffered yesterday against under Reagan
even fell back to 50% score kayaking
also on 50% he had some chances
yesterday to be down on but at the end
it was a draw yeah what does this game
about yeah there's also money involved
prize money and this game if this game
has a winner
it means that the winner would get like
substantially more money it's about what
the $40,000 difference so it's quite
quite some incentive to win certainly
okay let's see what happens
aronia playing whoops before yeah not a
finger fella probably intended he does
not do this very often he had played
before in in a training match against
chronic Beck much to the surprise of all
spectators but okay sometimes he does
that let's see what happens c5 okay
kayaking is playing a5 and c5 the night
offices main reply against a foe and
Aronian playing Knight c3 surprising
even more yeah here kayaking of course
being a knight of player has a slight
move order issue he would like for most
enters this audience the closed Sicilian
and other lines to play knight c6 but
the problem is that after Knight f3 or
me
ninety-two oops c'mon he cannot go back
to a night off anymore
this is no problem for them let's say
specially golf player I can actually go
to the sveshnikov like that or let's say
if you go with this move order you have
other options but it's not going to be a
night off with the knight on c6 the
night off player usually goes D six or a
six a six is actually quite an
interesting move it's not really bad at
all just feels a bit slow ish with a six
especially after move like f4 you sort
of ask yourself really a 16-day didn't I
couldn't I do something more let's say
oriented towards central control so it's
not bad it's just a bit risky yeah well
he went d6 and no Aronian yeah you could
expect them flat f4 here but he played
Bishop c4 which basically shows that
this is the kind of game that yeah
leaves theory quite immediately the last
time I saw this kind of setup was
probably in some under 12 championship
in the let's say one of the lower boards
just a very very simple development kind
of kind of move but ok you can do that
a3 keeping some space here for the
Bishop e6 d3 yeah it's all very
conservative what wide did here he gets
his piece out and decides later what to
do it looks very strange to be honest
from a white perspective but this is a
perfectly normal setup if you would have
this was colors reversed in the English
absolutely no one I just show that
absolutely no one would bat an eye if
let's say we have this position
that's something something like that is
a perfectly normal way to play as black
against the English and just keep in
mind this setup yeah just think of this
and now look at the game here you can't
put this on the board it's it's
perfectly identical in the other
position we had to H free plate because
Bishop and I'd say h6 plate because
Bishop to g5 was an idea h3 of course is
move that you can play in this structure
but it's not really serving in direct
purpose so on
what aronia just did is he gets his
pieces out and only at the later stage
decides on the plan of course compared
to the English Black has not fianchetto
the bishop be 592 yeah this is just the
same as in other games in the in the
double King pawn opening the knight on
c3 is very often not so well placed you
want to get it over let's say here and
now play C 3 and d 4 and if this would
actually happen we would get a position
that could have been easily arising from
other openings it can easily transpose
to French structures or even to ruler
PES structures if black can would play
the movie 65 in the in the next couple
of moves it's a pretty ridiculous move
to be honest because it just gives this
Knight a nice square but this would
actually look like typically like a
typical blue Lopez close Spanish type of
stuff yeah ok if I this as mentioned and
nonsense of course black is playing d5
keeping the pawn on e6 and pushing 445
in the center yeah of course white does
not want to exchange here on d5 or
anything he wants to grab the space play
d5 and now c3 of course it would be very
nice if white they would manage to play
d4 then they would have a French
structure
with the bishop being somewhat passive
on b7 and white can actually rather
quickly get the bishop to a good
diagonal back pointing towards h7 so d4
is I think a slight positional threat
and this is why kayaking plays deform
himself trying to prevent that or trying
to it's a wrong expression he really
prevented to d3 to deform why it took
and Bishop f4 a cause for concern might
be the default pond it could be a
weakness at some point and you have
considered the e4 square so sometimes
white may use this square for night 95
plate and droop to c1 this is all fairly
logical and before yeah black is trying
to play on the Queen side you know where
else you cannot do anything on the King
side and well the Queen side is you only
only play that you have so before make
sense in this in this way and now it's
an interesting moment aronia now plays
an interesting tactical movie plays
Bishop to g5 yeah looks weird at first
but rather is something hanging on on g5
um I think the next move backing our
canister is probably a mistake he plays
b3 looks like an aggressive aggressive
move but I think it's it's backfiring in
a way maybe you should have just taken
on g5 he ma I'm sorry like after b3
Bishop b1 I think he should have taken I
looked at the rough line in my in my
notes he played he played h6 but
probably Bishop takes g5 was was
somewhat was somewhat better me yeah now
I probably recaptures if you take here
it's like we'd be 6 attacking the rook
should be should be quite okay for black
so let's say here and now of course you
can have this funny situation if you go
here rook c5 leads to an interesting
position but cleaner is probably just to
play the the knight back Knight and
three and then weíll probably Queen to
b6 or a move of that type this is a
cause for concern the b3 pawn is it's
somewhat weak but still it was better
than the game I think in the game you
played age six and after this there was
94 and well this is a double attack on
the knight and black really does not
have any big alternatives to the capture
which happened it D takes yeah rook
takes us not really great it also has
the problem that it keeps the the bishop
boxed in so this and now we see the
problem the b3 pawn is actually very
difficult to defend him kayaking gave it
up in this way and it's now basically
porn down for not so clear compensation
really it's a bit of a weird part of the
game now because I really have a hard
time to understand what's happening now
to be to be perfectly honest here in
this position I mean what black is doing
as clay wants to get some play against
the b2 porn what else is there to attack
so it would be at least a my above
perfectly natural to play the move
before now - let's say - just get this
yeah this this pawn away from being
attacked all the time cover it of course
black will play a 5 but yeah let's say
something like that I mean white should
be somewhat better here shouldn't he I
mean it's it's two pawns at the moment
you will lose a5 but
let's say Quincy I shouldn't this be a
slight advantage for white yeah I think
it should be a bit a bit better for
white now he played a rook to d1 okay
attacking on d4 but well b2 is just
under so much fire now what what exactly
is white doing here I mean it cannot
really take here this looks really
awkward right Luke 2 e 2 and now why
does somewhat getting and it's getting a
bit passive here just defending the b2
thorn all the time that's yeah I don't
like it I mean maybe before an a5 was
ultimately equalizing for black at the
end but this just gives gives up any
initiative that white may had black now
has a huge compensation for the pawn
yeah I'd here in this position I think
probably he should go Bishop to d3
because only played Queen c1 and this
allowed an interesting an interesting
exchange sacrifice for coyoacán and he
played that he took on a3 and this is
just a very strong move which white
probably should have prevented yeah why
is this strong I mean white must capture
and Queen takes and now we have a
position if we do a quick counter Black
has got six points White's got six
points black as a whole exchange down
but it's still a very very good position
for black now because white has
absolutely no plane this Queen has
display on the dark squares there is a
possible Knight e5 coming later
attacking on f3 and white has absolutely
terrible Bishop on on b1
this is now a very one-sided position
and very very tough to to play in a
practical game we see that in the next
couple of moves this 95 business really
happened and it's almost impossible for
right now to even keep the exchange I
mean this is an additional an additional
problem
he played and rooks it to him it seems
that he should have played kingi to
giving the exchange back in this way
after rook c2 he got into some trouble
because the rook now is joining on the
fifth-ranked and this the spell struggle
he needed to play h4 covering on g5 not
oh not happy moose maybe maybe you
should have tried rook c8 but it's it's
just so ugly I mean it's just such an
ugly position look at that okay yeah now
where you go we're going with your queen
I mean you can try to go back but this
will check check lead to a total
disaster you have such a bad piece
coordination that you will win him you
will do cm with with them with stuff
like that
check this won't end well my g2 made
threatened yeah just just a very bad
position and very very unharmonious oh
this is why he went H for me
Bishop to b7 yeah it probably Bishop c6
was even a bit stronger and very tough
for white to defend as mentioned
especially in a in a practical in a
practical game the special ones e6 is
just a move to get it out from this
check on c8 so that black actually
threatens to take which should be seven
has a similar idea but white white hangs
on I mean it's not like he's losing out
right it's just such an uncomfortable
position to plane like a got the
exchange back and now put pawns on dark
squares which is of course from a
strategic point of view very sensible
maybe here this queen g3 move wasn't the
toughest he could he could have played
Queen two G form at least getting the
Queen's off this is yeah helping the
King but the long-term prospects are
still quite quite tricky White has those
badly paste pawns like will probably get
the bishop over here it's also a very
one-sided endgame yeah well he decided
to play Queen g3 maybe still should have
gone for the endgame it's very tricky to
to find the the best defense in this
type of position simply because you're
worse than any any sort of position and
to determine what's actually the best
the best defense is very very tough yeah
now this is coming rook f6 Andrew care
for yeah the the endgame with Queen G
for certain he was very uncomfortable
but this is not not much fun as well
Aronian or certainly hoping that this
move that he actually had played his
some is helping him which of course is
true it it's without this he would even
be completely busted
but after Roop takes check and these
moves it's still all the fun assists for
black iam he can always try to improve
play against the Sui King and the only
counter play that White has is this two
against one so maybe at some point the
b-pawn can provide for some counter play
we can
fast forward a bit and see that white
actually got the porn going but a black
of course still has some some more
things to try against them against the
king yeah going through this rather
quickly it is possible to do even more
thorough analysis of this part of the
game it's I think simply that black is
trying to improve slightly not trying to
spoil anything and tries to probe to
create more weaknesses white has gotten
the b-pawn but it's not going anywhere
b6 is just just protected and black is
simply taking its time and hoping that
with time going down there is some sort
of breakdown yeah just trying to
maneuver improving and probing and in
fact a couple of moves later Aronian is
committing a mistake we will see this
see this soon here it seems that it
should have played the Queen - G - King
- D - a king to g2 was played is it's
probably not yeah not the play will move
anymore now this bishop is attacked and
you have some some problems - to really
move it if you consider this this was
the problem and if you go here there is
this idea threatening rook H for Andrew
gage 3 yeah what the position look at
this
trapping the Queen
yeah this is what he tried to rope to
edge one but after Luke edge four it's
impossible anymore to avoid material
loss he gave away the bishop on you two
can still try it a couple of moves
hoping for the b-pawn and certainly
simply so I'm disappointed by the whole
cause of the tone check question based
at the check played that fall yeah the
h2 now Aronian resigns after 94 moves so
very long game in this final round of
the tournament
yeah I actually made this analysis quite
brief I I must say that I also had a six
hour game today which was quite tough
and I couldn't really bring up the time
to analyze 90 moves in great detail
maybe there was there was more to look
at in this in this kind of maneuvering
face it's always quite interesting to to
see how to improve those kind of
positions very slowly but I didn't
really have the opportunity in patience
to to do a very thorough analysis for
this game especially considering that it
was not relevant anymore for the for the
final result really of the tournament I
mean in terms of determining the
Challenger so on I hope you still
enjoyed the coverage it basically led to
a kayak in taking second place by the
way with a plus-one score and aronia and
even dropping to second to last place I
believe maybe maybe he's he's not on
field on the seventh level six place I'm
not I'm not quite sure about the the
tiebreak roots in this ex aspect but
he's on a minus one score which
certainly is a huge disappointment if
you look at his results before the
tournament and
expectations it certainly was not what
he had hoped for all right I hope you
enjoyed the game thanks for watching